so what was the tipping point where you
said you know what okay it's been three
years in the making I keep thinking
about it I keep talking about I'm gonna
come to LA I know that I've got to save
him some money whatever a lot time what
was it was there a moment like you're on
the subway and it was just like nothing
happened
it wasn't like a moment where I was
struck by inspiration or something like
it was it was I knew I wanted to come
out for three or four years and it was
just the fact that this was the first
year I was able to I had enough
residuals coming in that if I worked a
survival job I could save those up and
financially come out here that's what it
would like that's the only reason that
it took three or four years to get me
out here was just needed to save up
money you know a lot of people don't
mention that so we appreciate yeah
that's great yeah because I mean you
know you got to pay rent in New York
while I'm out here you know so it's it's
a little bit of a financial burden but
I'm definitely glad I came out was worth
it yeah and there's airfare and all of
that yeah yeah the airfare coming out
was a little cheaper because I was able
to buy it ahead of time
I didn't buy I wasn't sure when I was
gonna go back you know you come out
optimistically hoping you book something
in stay sure so I didn't I just bought
airfare back and it was like three times
the price Wow so yeah definitely buy buy
your tickets ahead of time okay good
good to know yeah well what other advice
did other people give you in terms of
coming out here that was a
well-intentioned helpful what else did
you hear um probably the most helpful
thing was when I got out here I because
it was a couple years in the making of
me thinking about pilot season and
there's all this stuff all this we're
going on I got out here and on a Friday
and like that Saturday I was like
alright Wednesday when something gonna
happen what's going on you know what
could a twit and the guy I'm staying
with who works in the industry he was
like comedy he was like you're gonna
drive yourself crazy if you're thinking
about it at this pace the whole time so
he was like do what you could contact
those people you know do
reach out to whatever you could but then
sit back and also know that your reps
are working for you and not to be so on
edge about like when's my phone gonna
ring you know so the the advice to not
be so hyped up was actually helpful
because then when I wouldn't my phone
did ring and I got an appointment it was
much more exciting than oh finally you
know so but as far as preparation for
coming out here I'm trying to think of
any advice I got that would be helpful
and most of it was just to like contact
the people you know out here set up that
base because it could be a little lonely
if you just come out and you know don't
know anybody having contacted anybody I
really don't know if I got any stellar
advice I'm sure I did I feel like I feel
like I'm gonna have a friend who's like
I I told you to do that and you did it
and it works but why didn't you why
didn't you say that but I don't know
what that is
so maybe it didn't happen
you